I get comments from people who are like
love your humility Alex I don't think
I'm that humble of a guy being real at
least internally in my own head I am
reminded daily of my inadequacy on the
business game because like right now
we've moved up a level in terms of like
now we're doing deals now we're
investing in companies we're taking on
big risk we're writing checks not to say
that owning one business and growing it
is not hard it absolutely is a different
kind of heart but like I'm getting into
this game and I'm absolutely the small
fish warm Buffet 90 billion dollars on
the trading made in apple in 2020. one
move even if I was exceptional it's
still going to take 20 years to prove it
so like I can't say anything and by that
point I'll probably have other guys who
were Titans at that point to
remind me of the fact that I'm not as
good as them